[Musique]
ouah de derrière c'est complètement
différent devant au soir alors ce sujet
concerne tout le monde
ce sujet est primordial pour le futur je
vais vous raconter l'histoire de mon ami
une amie avec qui j'ai perdu contact
pendant de nombreuses années et que j'ai
retrouvé fortuitement alors au détour de
nos conversations nous avons évoqué son
couple je me rappelle à l'époque elle
était tellement heureuse en social son
enthousiasme était communicatif je lui
ai demandé alors ça va êtes à quel
niveau elle m'a regardé avec beaucoup de
douleur dans le regard et elle m'a dit
oh non nous ne sommes plus ensemble
ça fait un moment que nous sommes
séparés petit moment de surprise et ici
il s'agit quand même d'une relation de
plus de 6 ans
qu'est ce qui s'était passé qu'est-ce
qui pouvait expliquer cela elle m'a dit
je ne ressentais rien
deuxième moment de surprise pendant tout
ce temps elle ressentait rien est-ce que
ce bonheur que je percevais était sûr
fait elle a continué et là j'ai compris
l'autre partie de la vérité
ce que je ne savais pas je ne ressentais
rien lorsqu'on faisait l'amour
j'ai eu beau essayer encore et encore
j'ai tenté différentes méthodes mais ça
ne marchait pas je n'étais pas satisfait
j'étais frustré et parce que je n'osais
pas lui en parler
nous nous sommes séparés il va sans dire
que j'ai été profondément touché par son
histoire c'est de mettre à sa place
elle n'était peut-être pas la seule
plusieurs études ont démontré que les
femmes atteignent moins de six fois sur
dix l'orgasme pour un ratio de 9 fois
sur 10 chez les hommes une disparité
relativement importante
combien de femmes comme elles sont
malheureuses dans leur couple à cause de
l'aspect sexuel
combien simule combien n'arrive pas à
quitter et reste malgré tout
combien au contraire se décide à aller
chercher leur faiseurs de puissance
combien se sont résolus à ne jamais dire
la vérité à leurs conjoints pour
comprendre ce phénomène il faut d'abord
faire un retour dans le passé un passé
une histoire qui n'ont pas vraiment pis
le plaisir de la femme au premier rang
dans le passé
la première utilité du sexe était la
reproduction
en effet les hommes et les femmes
avaient des rapports sexuels ensemble
dans le but de donner des enfants
une progéniture de la même manière
pendant longtemps on a observé que les
hommes avaient une tendance à
l'accumulation des conquêtes féminines
le roi guézo qui est un grand roi du
bénin à 20 arrêts me compter plus de
soins dix femmes
ces femmes étaient un peu comme sa
propriété
ça fait un peu comme un trésor de guerre
sauf que là c'est les femmes qui sont
les territoires conquis
[ __ ] également dans des pratiques
[Musique]
ancien vous verrez que certains jeunes
hommes avant d'obtenir le statut d'homme
avait l'obligation de déflorer une ou
deux filles comme ça il va montrer
qu'ils étaient de vrais hommes
c'était des rituels de passage a remis
ces pratiques pendant moi même d'une
région où pendant longtemps les
mutilations féminines génitales ont été
admises
j'ai une fois demandé à un sage de mon
village
pourquoi un bon dossier qu'on avait
pratiquée l'excision alors sa réponse
était étonnante
il m'a dit ma fille tu sais une femme à
qui on a enlevé le clitoris a moins de
chances d'être tenté de tromper son mari
comme cela elle sera fidèle et elle sera
très docile ce sera une femme vertueuse
et voiture ma fille dans notre tribu tu
sais des valeurs que nous préservons
alors je pense que derrière ces valeurs
ce vieux sage de mon village ne savez
peut-être pas que le clitoris un élément
important la sexualité de la femme
selon que vous soyez une femme
clitoridienne ou vaginale
on n'aurait pas l'orgasme de la même
façon alors si on vous autres le
clitoris vous comprenez que ça va être
un peu difficile d'atteindre cet organe
ce soir je vous parlais
du tabou de la sexualité ce tabou le
sexe en afrique se vit mais ne se
parlent pas il existe mais il est caché
la faible production des statistiques
nationales
toujours en afrique sur les attentes des
femmes en matière de sexualité vous
prouver à quel point il est difficile
d'interroger ce genre de thématique en
j'ai conduit une recherche sur les vécus
et les perceptions de la virginité chez
certains groupes de femmes des
conclusions de ma recherche je me suis
rendu compte que en matière d'
aspiration en sexualité
ces jeunes femmes disaient que leur mari
leur apprendre et où vous allez sûrement
pensé dans ce présent en 2019 enfin
l'étude et en 2016 ses contemporains
n'est ce pas vous vous demanderez
comment peut-on remettre à quelqu'un
toute la connaissance que l'on doit
d'avoir sur sa propre sexualité une
enquête et me disais oh je sais que ça
va me faire mal au début et ensuite au
fur et à mesure ça ira mon mari va
m'apprendre
et bien sachez que beaucoup de jeunes
femmes ne connaissent pas assez leur
corps pour pouvoir exiger un quelqu'un
degré de satisfaction
une enquête menée par ifop pour le
réseau social gamme girls who wanted
point org en 2018 sur un échantillon
représentatif de plus de 6000 fans a
montré que kylie à certaines pratiques
sexuelles qui sont plus épanouissante
que d'autres comme par exemple les tic
sexuelle d'oralité le cunnilingus la
fellation et cetera aux pays bas
plus de 90% de la population pratique le
69 et dans ce pays justement l' enquête
a montré que 38% des femmes étaient
généralement satisfaits voyez-vous là où
moi je suis né ici au bénin et dans ma
tribu il est impensable pour un homme de
ma tribu de donner du plaisir orale ou
d'en recevoir
mieux encore l'éducation
cette base de la cellule familiale au à
l'ordre dans l'école
la culture ne nous permettent pas
vraiment de pouvoir parler de sexualité
et encore moins de parler de chercher à
atteindre un seuil de satisfaction
j'imagine très mal aller en pharmacie
pour demander un aphrodisiaque
tout le monde le regardera très
bizarrement parce que ici je donne le
mauvais message le message de la
mauvaise fille combien de jeunes femmes
également en afrique et peut être
ailleurs dans le monde n'arrive pas dire
à leurs conjoints je préfére si
j'aimerais mieux que tu me donnes cela
essayons ceci essayons cela c'est
pratiquement impensable et se servent
vicieuse se perpétue dans le couple
mesdames et messieurs ce soir je me pose
la question de savoir à quoi ressemblera
le futur
le futur de la sexualité féminine
à quoi ressemblera le futur si les
femmes sont encore à une étape où elles
ont peur alors je me propose de vous
dire à quoi devrait ressembler la
sexualité féminine la sexualité féminine
du futur devrait être une sexualité
rudd de communication et d'expression
communication parce que la femme a
besoin d'être écouté d'être entendu elle
a besoin d'être valorisés elle a besoin
de ne pas avoir peur lorsqu'elle dit ses
fantasmes les envies ses références les
plus inavoués elle ne veut pas que vous
la jugez parce que je crois qu'elle ne
vous juge pas elle vous acceptez comme
vous êtes alors communiqué pourquoi pas
dire à votre partenaire est ce que tu
aimes ceux ci qu'est ce que tu veux ce
serait toujours un bon début
la sexualité féminine du futur une
sexualité qui selon moi ne doit pas être
sujette aux ego ego parce qu'il ne
faudrait pas prendre pour soi tous les
commentaires ego parce que l'homme ne
devrait pas voir dans une remarque une
insulte ou une atteinte à une quelconque
performance serait plutôt y voir
d'améliorer la vie de couple d'améliorer
le sexe en général la sexualité féminine
du futur encore pour moi serait une
sexualité et de découverte et
d'exploration puisque c'est du futur
qu'il s'agit ce sera un peu comme une
galaxie où nous serons tous des
cosmonautes
imaginez toutes ces zones 106,0 jeunes
du corps qui n'ont pas encore été
découverts oui cette sexualité là sur le
corps de la femme c'est lorsque vous
vous laissez aller à découvrir la liste
sexualité féminine de demain c'est une
sexualité singulière singulière parce
que toutes les femmes sont uniques avec
des caractéristiques uniques
cette sexualité ne s'embarrasse pas de
comparaison au décès de rapprochement
de similitudes vous savez moi je peux
être sensible des oreilles du coup vous
madame peut-être vous êtes sensible à un
autre endroit n'est ce pas alors la
singularity est pour moi ce qui
définirait la sexualité féminine dès
demain enfin la sexualité féminine du
futur serait une sexualité pluriel
pluriel parce qu'il y à une multiplicité
de pratique
pluriel partial mais fini tu es de champ
de possibles par exemple avec les
nouvelles technologies vous avez les
objets des jouets sexuels connectés
comme d'evry bourg masseur des pages pas
de ma soeur vous avez des houmas neither
et tout plein d'autres objets qui
peuvent stimuler le plaisir et le désir
de la femme cher monsieur
ne prenez pas mes propos à la légère
parce qu'un robot futuristic pourrez
vous remplacer un jour la sexualité
féminine de demain elle s'ouvre à vous à
condition de vous et soyez ouverts à
elle je rêve d'un futur où les hommes
pourront assumer pleinement leur rôle et
le statut qu'ils ont à jouer dans
l'épanouissement de la femme
je rêve d'un futur où les femmes
pourront jouir au tendon et le voudront
parce que la jouissance vous le savez
fait du bien les hormones libéré au
moment de leur case permet de réduire le
calme de réduire le stress plus tôt
l'anci été et vous permettre de planer
je rêve d'un futur os les rames pourront
être au travail comme dans la famille et
dans la société
des points de repos mais parce que au
niveau de leur sexualité
elles ont été comblés merci
[Applaudissements]